in der vergangen woche habe ich hier
die ungeimpften symbolisch um verzeihung
gebeten wegen der hitze und der
diskriminierung gehe sie über viele
monate ausgesetzt waren die reaktion war
überwältigend es und zum teil sehr
emotional ich habe daraus gelernt über
dieses thema müssen wir öffentlich reden
es ist notwendig dass wir besprechen
dass es millionen von menschen gibt in
deutschland die zutiefst verletzt sind
weil andere millionen sich überhaupt
nicht darum geschert haben was mit ihnen
passiert das geht nicht weiter und haben
die medien auch eine ganz gute rolle
gespielt es gibt viele übergriffe aus
den medien ich will ein paar erwähnen im
morgenmagazin des zdf sind ungeimpfte
als verfassungsfeind bezeichnet worden
beim berliner tagesspiegel ist der
wunderbare kolumnist harald martenstein
aus dem blatt geekelt worden weil er
geschrieben hatte wenn ungeimpfte mit
dem judenstern auf demonstrationen zögen
dann sei das zwar anmaßend aber nicht
antisemitisch das ist zweifelsfrei
richtig aus meiner sicht dann sind beim
rbb die ungeimpften mitarbeiter über
nacht aus dem sender geworfen worden
dass es am tag vor weihnachten verkündet
worden ich persönlich bin in einem ruf
mörderischen artikel als schutzpatron
der ungeimpften bezeichnet worden das
hatte die absicht mich als
journalistisch zu erledigen ich weiß
also ein bisschen wovon ich rede aber
ich bin ja geimpft und nicht ungeimpft
und ich finde wir müssen hier
wir müssen hier öffentlich etwas für
diese menschen tun der bundespräsident
hat zunächst mal muss ich ein werfen wir
haben uns ja inzwischen was die basis
der ganzen diskussion angeht daran
gewöhnt wir haben eingesehen dass es was
die infektions leistungen angeht also
die ansteckungsgefahr angeht keinen
unterschied zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften gibt und das ist außerdem in
den in den
intensivstationen geimpfte neben
ungeimpften liegen da können wir gar
keinen unterschied mehr feststellen
trotzdem wird aber diese kampagne gegen
die ungeimpften fortgesetzt ich möchte
einen satz aus der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung vom gesamt
phase vom vergangenen wochenende
vorlesen zitat und wer sich bis heute
keine spritze hat geben lassen die
maßnahmen für übertrieben und das virus
für harmlos hält sollte ohnehin nicht
der erste sein der seine freiheit zurück
bekommt das ist ein ungeheurer satz das
heißt in diesem land gibt es zwei sorten
von freiheit die erste klasse haben
diejenigen sich haben impfen lassen und
die zweite klasse haben vielleicht
diejenige die sich nicht impfen lassen
der bundespräsident hat kürzlich gesagt
es gebe eine der hat die die stille
mehrheit wie er es genannt hat im land
aufgerufen sie sollten sich zu wort
melden mit der stimmenmehrheit meinte er
die geimpften die sollten sich gegen die
ungeimpften zu worte melden ich finde er
selbst sollte sich zu wort melden um den
ungeimpften ihre rechte zurück zu geben
und ihnen gerechtigkeit widerfahren zu
lassen wir brauchen keinen
bundespräsidenten der eine mehrheit
aufwiegelt wir brauchen ein der die
minderheit schützt
als es zu dem thema kann ich nur sagen
so wie ich es lebe und auch eigentlich
die meisten in meinem umfeld
ich verhalte mich so dass ich möglichst
andere nicht gefährde
und sind sie dann gehe ich bin gepustet
und werde mich auch ein viertes mal ich
werde wenn es jemand sagt der von
medizin mehr ahnung hat als ich und das
sind ganz viele und wenn die sagen du
musst dich zweimal im jahr impfen lassen
dann werde ich es machen nicht nur zum
eigenen schutz sondern auch um
sicherzugehen dass mein umfeld geschützt
ist und auch
uns dabei zu unterstützen dass die
pandemie london vorbei ist dass wir ein
annähernd normales leben führen können
dass wir auf partys gehen können dass
hier wieder spaß haben können
dass ich nicht wenn ich im zug sitze
nachher sein versprechen was nie
eingelöst wurde also geimpft und
gepustet und was ja alles darf und
trotzdem dürfen die leute ja nicht ich
finde es schlimm dass ich fünf stunden
im zug sitzen muss mit einer maske und
mir ist dann über hinterher und ich will
dass das irgendwann mal aufhört und ich
tue alles dafür dass das irgendwann mal
aufhört für uns hier in deutschland und
das ist mir wichtiger als dass es
eventuell eine nebenwirkung gibt oder
dass ich meine demokratische freiheit
ausleben kann mir ist alles andere
wichtiger als diese beiden punkte noch
nimmt oftmals höhere ohne verein bin
stehe ich auch nicht auf die straße
ansonsten trainieren lassen erst mal
vorteil ohne gibt's auch verglichen weil
auch keine menschen keine politiker
tätig angreifen weil die anderer meinung
sind als ich möchte dass meine meinung
respektiert wird genau so wie ich auch
die meinung der ungeimpften respektiere
und sage wenn du da ängste hast und es
nicht machen willst aus irgendwelchen
gründen mache es nicht wo sich also
heute das schlimme ist dass die pandemie
bei manchen die sehnsucht nach
einfachheit sich dann auch so auswirkt
moralische rigorosität
sündenbock suche sündenbock denken
einerseits muss ich ein york ist ein
bisschen widersprechen es gibt schon
noch ein unterschied bei der viruslast
und auch bei der schwere der
erkrankungen zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften aber trotzdem für mich ist
ganz wichtig als liberale es ist die
entscheidung von erwachsenen menschen
selbst welche medizinischen eingriffe
sie an sich vornehmen lassen und das
muss ich respektieren und der
unterschied ist allerdings unter omikron
erst recht nicht mehr so stark
was das thema infektionsrisiko und so
weiter angeht deshalb bin ich gegen eine
impfpflicht ich glaube auch nicht
übrigens dass manche ungeimpften die
sich so ein bisschen jetzt allgemein als
opfer stilisieren oder als seien sie
mündiger als alle die sich geübt haben
dass es genauso falsch aber ich habe was
gegen diese suche nach sündenböcken und
ganz gefährlich an dem was sie gastiert
haben ist nämlich diese denke als ginge
es um bestrafung oder belohnung im
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat ist das keine
frage von gnade oder wohlwollen obmann
freiheit hat sondern der staat darf nur
sowie nicht wie möglich so viel wie
unbedingt nötig die freiheitsrechte
einschränken und da und das ist einfach
so schlimm dieses bevormundende dieses
erzieherische dieser impetus und der
greift immer mehr um sich wir müssen
noch mal erkennen dass wir unsere
erwartungen ans impfen ich bin genauso
wie sie gemeistert ständig
zurückgenommen haben anfangs haben wir
gedacht wenn wir geimpft sind stecken
wir uns auch gar nicht mehr an und wir
können noch andere nicht anstecken das
wurde auch übrigens mit der masken
pflicht verbunden dann haben wir gemerkt
das stimmt ja gar nicht besondern wir
sind als gebucht hat es selber in der
lage andere menschen anzustecken ich
habe im moment meine beiden töchter und
deren männer sind alle gewusst hat und
alle corona krank im selben moment die
an gar kein umgang mit ungeimpften weil
sie darauf achten dass haben sie also
von gm mit
na ja das schöne sache für die ich mich
entschuldigen wenn ich hab's auch wie
oft bei villach gemacht ich werde ab
jetzt nur noch sagen menschen die sich
gegen die impfung entschieden haben
gm habe ich zwei plaketten die wir
wieder raus ja aber das kriegen zu
kompliziert wenn ich hier so einen
kleinen vortrag halte dann muss ich
einen einfachen begriff dafür haben und
es ist wird jeder verstehen dass ich ihn
nicht böse meine tue ich auch nicht also
wir haben uns dann immer weiter
zurückgezogen bis auf den jetzigen
letzten bis auf die letzte letzte insel
dass wir sagen wer geimpft ist
jedenfalls geschützt vom schweren
krankheitsverlauf das stimmt auch nicht
ganz weil es liegen gebucht hatte auf
den intensivstationen die auch schwer
krank sind und es sterben auch
gemusterte also alles sehr fragwürdig
ich will jetzt nichts gegen das impfen
sagen bin dreimal geimpft aber
jedenfalls die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen dafür verantwortlich machen dass
das dass die infektionsraten steigen und
dass das land nicht herauskommt aus der
pandemie das ist eine wirklich üble
geschichte aber sein sein dreht ist das
schwarzweiß und da erwarte ich den
bundespreis die impfung bringt weder den
absoluten ausgang aus der pandemie wie
es die impfpflicht befürworter behaupten
aber es ist auch falsch wie es die
impfgegner behaupten dass sie nichts
nütze und nicht sinnvoll sein sie ist
für die allermeisten menschen im
sinnvoller schutz vor einem schweren
verlauf aber sie bringt eben nicht den
völligen die völlige sicherheit in den
völligen ausgang aus
müssen wir daher differenz ich habe
gemerkt an dem was das an reaktionen kam
auf meine bitte um verzeihung dass weine
eine
symbolische geschichte wir haben hier
immer nena und ich haben immer der
verunglimpfung der der nicht geimpften
widersprochen
aber
dass die ungeimpften biete ich da
gemeldet haben rechtsradikal wären oder
verschwörungstheoretiker oder sonstige
spinner das kann ich nicht sagen sondern
ich glaube mein eindruck war dass sind
menschen aus der mitte der gesellschaft
und das müssen wir endlich mal begreifen
dass das keine randfiguren sind
irgendwie obskur sondern sie sind mitten
aus der gesellschaft das sind ärzte
dabei rechtsanwälte krankenschwestern
das wissen wir doch alles krankenpfleger
die jeweils ihrer individuelle
begründung haben warum sie sich impfen
lassen möchten das ist auch ihr gutes
recht weil es ist nicht vorgeschrieben
und dann müssen wir sie auch verteidigen
und dürfen sie nicht so niedermachen
lassen wie das passiert ist solider als
schutzpatron der menschen die sich dann
doch ein kompliment an lass mich heute
aber es war damals in vernichtende
absicht geschrieben weil damals las ich
da so wie die ungeimpften und unter
seinen schutzmantel nimmt das ganze jahr
über ein schlimmes zeichen unserer finde
ich nicht nicht mehr gut debattenkultur
das nicht mehr über die qualität der
argumente beurteilt wird was jemand sagt
sondern darüber wer dafür beifall
klatschen ein riesenproblem auch für
politiker man kann das richtige sagen
wenn man von den falschen leuten bei
fall kriegt wird es darüber diffamiert
und das ist falsch wir müssen doch in
der sache argumentieren und die qualität
der argumente auseinandernehmen und
nicht danach irgendwie sich richten wir
applaudiert oder nicht sonst gibt man
übrigens auch den falschen leuten die
ganz große dort unsere denjenigen die
noch bestimmen was man sagen darf oder
was nicht wir müssen über die qualität
der argumente streiten genau da will ich
noch ein sachliches argument einbringen
und zwar der hauptgrund warum überhaupt
über eine impfpflicht gesprochen wurde
oder wo man ermutigt wurde sich zu
impfen das war bevor überhaupt ein
impfstoff da war hat man gedacht
hoffentlich kommt einer hoffentlich
kommt eines klar vor zwei jahren her da
hat man sich geimpft wie sie gerade
gesagt haben und dann dachte man nach
mit der zweiten impfung alles gut so
wurde es ja vom vorherigen
gesundheitsminister auch propagiert dann
hieß es okay das reicht es doch nicht
mehr brauchen die dritte impfung das
hauptargument muss immer gegen warum
muss man alles soll man sich impfen oder
warum gibt es doch dann leider die
intensivstation komplett überlastet sind
das teile ich nach wie vor wenn die
intensivstation überlastet sind dann
bricht das gesundheitssystem zusammen
habe ich erwarte ja von dem staat
insbesondere von den deutschen staat ja
dass er dafür in der lage ist das
gesundheitssystem
so in wie sagt man auf in schacht war
oder so modern zu führen dass genau hier
kein engpass entsteht ja und das ist die
hauptaufgabe von gesundheitsminister
nicht als er uns einsteigt ja nicht dass
er uns hier einschränkt damit sondern er
ist dafür verantwortlich nicht nochmal
locker und nochmal einschränkungen jetzt
schon wieder erzählen in drei oder was
im september oktober kommt dann die
vierte welle jürgen hat das schon wieder